- Back when the British
empire was colonizing
all of this land, they drew a line.
The line went right along
this little mountain range
and it was meant as a boundary.
Back in London, there were saying
that no English settler was allowed
to settle West of this line.
The British empire did this
because they were worried
that if settlers started
to expand into the West
they would bring the British Empire
into a war with native populations.
They also didn't wanna
unnecessarily piss off France
who also had land in the West.
So they told their settlers to settle,
but not pass this line.
And then the settlers
completely ignored it.
(upbeat music)
These settlers would
eventually declare independence
from Britain and start their own country.
And from there the flood gates were open
for westward expansion.
- [Announcer] A frontier
people had remade a continent.
Virtually all productive land
had been put to the plough.
A free and independent
way of life prevail.
(upbeat music)
- This westward blitz
was made possible through
the mass slaughter of people
who were living on this land,
which this little time lapse ignores.
How that all went down will be
the subject of another video.
But right now I want to
talk about what happened
when the U.S. got here.
(upbeat music)
It's the mid 1800s and
the U.S has 27 States
and a bunch of territories in the West,
but the country doesn't stretch from sea
to shining sea quite yet.
At this point, they start to bump in to
the recently independent
country of Mexico.
(upbeat music)
The Northern part of Mexico
was called Tejas or Texas,
and it was populated
mainly with native groups
who had nothing to do
with the U.S. or Mexico.
They had just been living
there for centuries.
So Mexico is looking at this
fairly new sparsely populated
part of their country
and thinking what you know,
what do we do with all this land?
They want to incentivize people to go with
and settle in this land
so it would potentially be
more economically productive
for the country of Mexico.
So they made a plan.
They started to rent huge swaths of land
to American settlers so
that they would come in
and settle the land.
And then return, these American settlers
would recruit more settlers
to come in and settle the land
again, all with the hope that
it would benefit Mexico's
economy eventually.
It did exactly the opposite.
American settlers fled into Texas
onto this newly rented land,
just as the Mexican government hoped for,
but with them they brought slaves,
which was totally illegal
in Mexico at the time.
They also brought with them an attitude
of independence and frontier fever.
This American obsession with
moving West to settle new land.
- [Narrator] The westward movement,
was like a great title wave.
The odd corners were rapidly engulfed.
- Mexico soon realized that
this plan completely backfired
and that the Americans that
had rented land from them
were now not interested
in having Mexico as their government.
So Mexico sends in the
military to remind the settlers
that they're still in Mexico
and that they're technically
renting this land from Mexico.
Well, this eventually escalated
and they started to fight all out battles.
And the American settlers lost.
The big battle here was called
the Battle of the Alamo.
This guy, David Crockett, who was
like the symbol of Westward
expansion, died in this battle.
And this loss spurred even more settlers
to come to Texas and joined
the next fight against Mexico,
which the American settlers won.
And with that, they declared a new nation
independent of Mexico,
the Republic of Texas.
And now the map looks like this.
A newly declared country
of American settlers
in between Mexico and the United States.
But not everyone actually agreed
that the map looked like this.
While Mexico conceded
that they lost the war.
They disputed this map saying
that the border of the
new Republic of Texas
was actually here.
And that all of this was still Mexico.
So now you have a big land
dispute between Mexico
and the Republic of Texas.
Well soon it's 1845
and Texas becomes the 28th
state of the United States.
And yet this land is still disputed,
but now it's a land dispute
between the United States
of America and Mexico.
Let's keep in mind that
despite all of this map drawing
there are still loads of
native peoples who've lived
on this land for years and
are now being suffocated
by all these nations
trying to take their land.
Again, that's another episode
and it's an important episode
and I want to do it justice.
But for now what happens next
in the Mexico story gets kind of nuts.
And the reason it gets
kind of nuts is mainly
because of this guy,
president James K. Polk.
James Polk wins the presidency
and comes into office with
a list of four big things
he wants to do.
It's his big wishlist.
At the top of this wishlist
is Polk desire to capture
this very specific part of Mexico,
which is called California.
Remember that at the time, the
U.S. didn't actually stretch
from the Atlantic to the Pacific.
The U.S. had colonized
portions of Oregon territory,
but it was kind of confusing
because there were kind of
competing with the French
and the British, and they
didn't actually own it yet.
But you'll notice that Oregon
was also on Polk's shortlist,
but first California.
He first tried to buy
California from Mexico
for $25 million.
Mexico flat out said no.
So Polk decides to pull
an incredibly dirty move.
Remember this big old
swath of disputed territory
that the U S inherited
when they admitted Texas into the union,
James Polk was pissed off that
Mexico didn't take his offer
to buy California.
So he sends a small group of troops
into this disputed territory
and has the March right up to here,
right across from the river
that separates what
everyone agrees is Mexico.
But according to Mexico,
they've already been in Mexico
as soon as they crossed
into this dispute territory,
which Mexico believes is theirs.
So the Mexican army is sent to respond
to what looks like an oncoming attack
from the United States.
This is exactly what Polk wanted.
A group of 1,600 Mexican soldiers attack
this small group of 80
Americans killing 11 of them
and capturing the rest.
They easily one, since
they were outnumbered
by like a magnitude of like 20.
But this is exactly what Polk needed
to get his wishlist going.
After this battle, Polk
goes to Congress and reports
that the Mexicans have
quote, invaded our territory
and shed American blood
upon American soil.
Even though this wasn't
necessarily American soil;
it was disputed territory
that most people thought
was rightfully Mexico.
But it didn't matter.
The death of Americans was
enough to rally Congress
around declaring war with Mexico.
The U.S. easily won this war
and they did it pretty quickly.
Remember that the taking
over of Texas was originally
a bunch of settlers who band
together, made a militia,
fought Mexico on their own
and declared the Republic of Texas.
Not super great, but at least it wasn't
like a government leader
sending his soldiers in
that he knows, are going to
lose to provoke another country
to kill those soldiers
so that he can use democratic processes
and institutions to make war all so
that he can take over
land from that country.
I mean, Polk really wanted California.
There were critics of this in the time.
One of whom was this guy who
said that letting Polk force
the country into war
with Mexico was quote,
allowing him to make war at pleasure.
And Abe hit the nail on the head.
This whole war was started and fought at
the pleasure of this
president, James K. Polk.
So anyway, the U S easily wins the war.
They pay Mexico $15 million
and Mexico gave up all of this.
As a part of this loss.
Mexico also conceded
all of this disputed territory
making it officially a part
of the U S state of Texas.
The U.S. had grown significantly
in just a couple of years.
And Polk got his California.
The U.S.could have taken more land.
Some American lawmakers at the time
wanted to take all of Mexico.
And militarily they likely
could have done this,
but they only took this part
of Mexico because it was
the most sparsely populated
mainly by native Americans.
One Senator at the time, who
happened to be pro-slavery,
argued on the Senate floor
against taking all of Mexico.
Saying quote, we have never
dreamt of incorporating
into the Union, any,
but the Caucasian race,
the free white race.
Are we to associate with
ourselves as equal companions
and fellow citizens, the Indians
and mixed races of Mexico?
In other words, let me put it plainly.
The policy was let's search
for land where we exterminate
the natives and settle white people
instead of let's take land
where there's already big populations
that are non white people
that we would have to
bring into our country.
This is a policy that
informed American expansion
and imperialism for a very long time.
And it's what guided a lot
of what land we took over
and what land we didn't take over.
Okay, so through this
unprovoked racially tinge war
Polk checked off California from his list.
And just the next month
Oregon was organized into a territory
after working out a deal with the British.
Polk had exterminated anyone in his way.
And now he had a coast to coast country.
A few years later
they bought this little
piece of land from Mexico
and this completed the Southern
border that we know today.
One that was forged first from a rebellion
of American settlers,
then a war at the
pleasure of James K. Polk.
And then finally that little
purchase there at the end.
The native people and
Mexicans that lived here when
the U.S. took it over.
And let's be clear on something
that is not a small number.
They were predictably oppressed
as white settlers fled into this region
often looking for gold.
Native people were driven from their land
and the rights of Mexican
property owners were erased in
the name of a state constitution
that only let white people vote.
- [Narrator] This land after
a little more than a century
and a half had become great nation,
the United States of America.
- So, the U S stole Mexico in the 1800s,
partly because they opened
their borders to Americans
to let them in to work their land,
which is just a very
strange, full circle irony.
Especially because today you
go to the U.S.-Mexico border
and we do everything to make it clear
that this side of that wall is U.S.
when just a few years
ago it was all Mexico.
I wish like the Hawaii video
I had some high note to
end on here, but I don't.
So, so yeah.
These stories about how the
U.S. expanded teach me so much
about how the U.S. got it
shape and how the world works
and how countries grow and change.
And I've really been learning
a lot by delving into these.
Before you go, I want to tell you
about a really important
resource online called Skillshare
who's the sponsor of this video.
But more importantly
Skillshare is a platform
that I've used for many years
to learn a lot of the skills
that I used in today's
video and I'm always using.
Animation, video, design.
All of these things I taught myself.
I didn't go to school for.
Skillshare was a key
part of that education.
I've taken loads of Skillshare
courses over the years.
Well, before they came to sponsor video.
And I'm just, I really
believe in this model.
And you can get two
months of unlimited access
to all Skillshare tutorials for free
if you click the link in my description,
which you click that link it
helps support this channel,
but more importantly it
engulfed your ability
to start learning new skills.
If you're looking for a course to try out,
I want to recommend this
course on animation loops.
It's called creating crazy
animation loops in after effects.
This course really lays out step by step,
how you can concept and
design interesting designs,
but then how you can loop them in ways
that create a much more powerful
and interesting animation.
So check that out.
But honestly, Skillshare
has courses of all kinds,
not just animation and video,
but like cooking and entrepreneurship
and like a million different topics.
Thousands of courses.
You can get access to all of
them for free for two months
if you click that link.
And then after that, it's like,
I think less than 10 bucks a month
if you do the annual subscription,
which for what you're
getting, like, I'm sorry.
It's like, it's like a full on education
in like creative arts.
And you're getting that
for 10 bucks a month.
Like, it seems like a no brainer.
That's just me.
I love learning on the internet.
So
check out that link.
Thank you, Skillshare
for sponsoring this video
and supporting this channel.
Thank you all for supporting
this channel by being here
and leaving your feedback.
And I will see you in the next video.
See you later.